machine learning has revolutionized the
business world and is helping us
building sophisticated application to
solve challenging business problem using
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning models you can solve problems
using classification and regression and
clustering algorithm in this video we
will discuss a supervised machine
learning algorithm in Python called
logistic regression logistic regression
can be used to solve both classification
and regression problem just a quick info
for you if you want to upskill yourself
master Ai and machine learning skills
and landar your dream job or grow in
your career then you must explore simply
learn's cohort of various Ai and ml
programs simply learn offers various
certification and post-graduate program
in collaboration with some of the world
leading universities like Von perdu
ctech I Cano and many more through our
courses you will gain knowledge and work
ready expertise in skills like
generative AI prompt engineering
explainable AI machine learning
algorithms and over a dozen others
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple project
and learn from industry experts working
in Top Tire Product Company and
academicians from top university after
completing these courses thousand of
Learners have transitioned into an AI or
ml role as a fresher or moved onto a
higher paying job Ro and profile if you
are a passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the print comand
and the description box to find an AIML
program that fits your experience and
areas of Interest so moving forward
let's take a quick look at supervised
learning what is supervised learning in
supervised machine learning machines are
trained using label data also known as
training data to predict results here
label data refers to a group of data
have been tagged with one or more names
and the data is already known to the
machine in the real world supervised
machine learning can be used for image
object detection Predictive Analytics
spam detection and customer sentiment
analysis and many more supervised
learning problems can be further
classified into regression and
classification problem in classification
problem that output variable is a
category such as red or blue disease or
no disease true or false and many other
in regression in regression problem the
output variable is the real continuous
value such as dollars or F so now let's
move forward and have a look on what is
logistic regression logistic regression
is a statical technique for creating
machine learning models with a binary of
dependent variable it describes the
relationship between two variable
dependent variable and or independent
variable which can be nominal ordinal or
interval types this method employs the
logistic function also called the
sigmoid function with output values
constraint between 0o or 1 let's take an
example of logistic function so we can
use to find the prob ility of a vle
breaking down depending on how many
years it has been used since it was
service last so here is how you can
interpret the result from the graph to
decide whether the vehicle will break
down or not so moving forward let's see
advantages of logistic regression
algorithm the first one is logistic
regression performs better when the data
is linearly separable the second one is
it does not require too many
computational resources as it's highly
interpretable the Third third one is
there is no problem scaling in the input
features it does not require tuning the
fourth one is it is easy to implement
and train a model using logistic
regression now moving forward let's see
how does a logistic regression
algorithms Works let's take an example
an organization wants to determine an
employee salary increase based on their
performance for this purpose a logistic
regation algorithm will help them decide
plotting a regression line by
considering the employee performance as
the independent variable and the Sal
increase as the dependent variable will
make their task easier so now what if
the organization wants to know whether
an employer would get a promotion based
or not so the linear graph won't be
suitable in this case as such as we clip
at the line at zero and one and convert
it into a sigmoid curve S curve So based
on threshold values the organization can
decide whether an employee will get an
salary increase or not so there are some
mathematical function which can help you
on finding logistic regression analysis
so these are some mathematical functions
you can use in logistic regression
analysis so LR function logistic
regression is statical model that uses
the logistic function or logic function
in mathematics as the equation between X
and Y so the logic function Maps y as a
sigmoid function logic regression with
multiple independent variable in many
cases multiple explanatory variables
affect the value of the dependent
variable so to model such input data set
logistic regression formulas assume a
linear relationship between a different
independent variables so you can modify
the S function and compute the final
output and the last one is the logic
function the logic function you can also
s the log odds the logic model can also
determine the ratio of success to
failure or log odds so moving forward
let's see some application of logistic
function I repeat so moving forward
regression the first one is banking
using the logistic regression algorithms
Banks can predict whether a customer
would default on loans or or not the
second one is to predict the weather
condition or a certain place sunny windy
rainy or humid You can predict from
logistic regression the third one is
e-commerce e-commerce companies can
identify buyers if they are likely to
purchase a certain product the fourth
one is companies can predict whether
they will gain or lose money in the next
quarter year or month based on their
current performance so now moving
forward let's jump into our Jupiter
notebook to implement logistic
regression demo so now here we will do
loan prediction using uh logistic
regression so first I will change the
name loan
prediction using logistic regression
right so we will import some major
libraries like numpy import numpy as NP
and
import pandas s
PD then import M plot lip
do p
plot as PLT for the graphs and all then
we will import
cbon as SNS so moving forward we will
import one data set ed. read uncore
CSV
and Loan
file.
CSV
okay spelling
mistake
yeah
okay loan file. CSC okay let me check
the file name
first so here file name is loan file
just loan file only so moving forward we
will do
some
function let's check so this is our data
set so in this there are like multiple
columns name loan ID gender marry
dependence education this this then
let's check the info of the data
set BF
doino so as you can see so we have 13
columns right total 13 columns and the
column type is this object object float
and object okay the memory usage and all
once again let's check how many rows
DF do shape so as you can see we have
614 rows and 13 columns present in our
data set okay
we'll
check using describe as
well yes so this is the count of the
particular column then mean then
standard deviation minimum that 25% of
particular column okay the maximum Val
value the 75% of that particular column
value okay let's check how many null
values are there so for that we'll write
is
null because first we have to sort our
data set for the better
predictions okay so loan ID don't have
any null value gender have married
have okay right so now let's do some
data cleaning here for data cleaning
we'll run right
DF
loan amount equal to
DF loan
amount do fill
na okay
DF loan amount
dot mean okay
PF right so for credit history we'll
check
DF then
credit
history to
DF credit
history do filler
name so I'm filling the particular cells
with the median or mean values
okay then
DF credit history
again history.
median right so now again let's check is
n
do okay fine credit history now zero as
you can see here you can see the credit
history is 50 50 N values were there now
zero and one more loan amount okay 22
now loan amount is zero so DF do
drop
na
Place equals to
true then now DF do
shape so now as you can see we have
dropped the all
the uh you null values rows as you can
see the 542 here before it was 614 right
so now let's moving forward we will do
some Eda okay some data
representation so here what we will do
we will plot some graphs right so I will
write a PLT do figure then figure
size equals to 100 comma 50 then SNS do
set font
scale = to
5 and PLT do
subplot
331 SNS dot count
plot then DF where I need
gender then Hue will
be
DF then loan
status right so I will do the same for
the Merit and the education then the
self-employed then the property area
right so I can copy
this and paste it
here right one more I need
okay then I will change the name but I
need
Merit C32 333 for
Education 34 for
self-employed
self
employed the and for property
area right here I will
write okay let's run it it's loading
some error is there okay g capital
here so now as you can see these are
some bar graph like how many married are
there loan status yes or no the blue one
is yes okay for the education for the
self-employed so these are some warnings
you can ignore them right so moving
forward we will check some loan status
so I will write
here I want only loan
status do
replace y to 1 and N to zero okay so
later it will be good to check comma 1
in place equals to true
okay same for
no no
status dot
replace n comma Z comma in place equ to
True okay loan status S capital
here
cancel it is nothing just a typo mistake
okay so here I will write DF the
loan
status then value count
value
counts okay so yes are 376 and the no
are 166 right so we'll check with the
gender marriage and the dependent okay
so for that I will write DF do
gender equals to DF
dot
gender g capital
here
dot map then male is one
comma
female is
zero
right then I will write DF
gender dot value
counts okay so now I gave male to one
and female to zero okay so this is the
gender count right so I will do this for
Mary as well as the dependents okay for
all the education s employed property
area okay so what we can do we can just
copy it paste it here and we can
change right for the
mar
Merit
for yes to
one and no to zero so let me do it fast
for you and then I I will get back to
you so as you can see we have done with
the all the value counts here like
property area self-employed education
dependence married okay we have all the
accounts so now let's see the loan
amount value count loan
amount dot
value
accounts okay so this is the loan amount
value account that and we'll check the
loan amount value
term for that I will write
loan
amount
to the dot
value
counts right then let's check the credit
history which is very important factor
for the
loan
credit
history do
value
counts
okay right so now let's check DF do
head so now as you can see we have this
see one means
male here you can see
we gave married the gender male equals
to one then female is zero so this is
this ID is male ID right then 01 we have
all gave here like 0 1 01 right if the
guys graduate so one not graduate so
zero same employed is yes or no like
that right so now we'll do the train
test split okay for that I will write
from SK SK learn
do model
selection
import
train
test split then from
Escalon dot
linear model
import logistic
regression okay then I will write
fromal done
import Matrix
okay run
it so here I will assign X = to DF do
iog then 1 ratio 542
rows then from 1 to 12 columns dot
values then y equals to DF do iog that
same
okay 1 to
542 row then col dot
values okay so here I will do X train
comma
X test comma
y train comma y test equ
to
train
test
split then X comma y
comma test size equals to 0.3 0.3 means
70% will be the training data and the
30% will be the testing data right
random State equals to Z got it so now
let's do the logistic regression let's
apply models to
logistic
degression then model dot
fit X train comma y
train then
LR _
prediction equals to model do predict
then X test right then print logistic
regression accuracy equals
to comma
metrix dot
accuracy
underscore score then I will write here
L
predictions comma
y test right so as you can see we have
the accuracy of almost 79% or you can
say 78% right so now let's see the
prediced values so for that
print y prediction predicted
value values comma LR
prediction okay then
print y
test
comma Yore
test so as you can can see so these are
some predicting values like one means
that guy or girl have the loan okay loan
status is yes loan prediction status is
yes then zero means no right and the
testing we did the here zero okay the
predictor value is one right so these
are some prediction values and the
testing values so this is how you can do
loan prediction using logistic
regression okay so we have come to end
of this video if you want this full code
you can comment down below and if you
want this file loan file so you can
check out from the description box
below and if you have any queries so
please comment down in the Box we will
reach out to you as soon as possible
thank you for watching the video please
do like share and subscribe thank you
and keep learning with simply Lear
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here